hallo leute heute drehen wir wieder ein
video aus unserer reihe über die
wichtigsten deutschen werben für euch es
geht heute um das werk stellen mit dem
werk stellen werden auch viele weitere
werben durch das hinzufügen eines präfix
wie zb hinstellen oder ausstellung
gebildet daher stellen wir euch nächstes
werk stellen mit der präsens
kommunikation vor und werden euch danach
noch einige beispiele von verben zeigen
die aus dem werk stellen und einem
freiwilliges gebildet werden los geht's
habt ihr gerade gemerkt dass sich in dem
intro sogar schon eine kombination mit
dem werk stellen genutzt habe vorstelle
dann geht's jetzt los
[Musik]
ich stelle
du stellst er sie es stellt wir stellen
ihr stellt sie stelle mit stellt
das boot auf meinen kopf
mit stellt die milch auf den tisch neben
die milch stellt er zwei tassen stellst
du die milch bitte den kühlschrank
ich stelle den kaktus auf die
fensterbank
seit wann stellen wir den dreckigen
schuhe auf den tisch stellen ihm auf dem
boden oder werfe sie auf dem boden
vorstellen
ich möchte mich noch bei den neuen
nachbarn vorstellen dann nicht abstellen
und weg stelle mit stellt die möbel auf
der palette ab mal so komme ich ja an
gar nichts mehr dran
kannst du dir immer wieder weg stellen
[Musik]
zusammen stellen
wir sind jetzt am strand und ich habe
unseren kleines picknick
zusammengestellt
eigentlich ist
[Musik]
hast du mir gerade ein bein gestellt
stelle
es ist super wenn ich am strand muss mir
mal gemalt zusammenbinden aber erstmal
muss ich das bier hinstellen aufstellen
jetzt müssen wir erstmal das strand so
vor aufstellen
[Musik]
unterstellen es soll gleich regnen
also stelle ich mich lieber unter
[Musik]
an stellen mit ist offensichtlich kalt
dabei ist es überhaupt nicht kalt der
soll sich mal nicht so anstellen ich
stelle das radio an
hallo hallo karin anel hadzic im podcast
im radio nein ich der easyjet rodgers
läuft nicht im radio das habe auf allen
gängigen drogba steps schaut mal hier
bei kathrein da könnt ihr nämlich
mitglied von easy german werden und
bekommt unter anderem ein interaktives
transkript und bonusmaterials zu unserem
podcast
es gibt mittagessen
ich stelle mich an wir stellen und durch
stellen
hallo hallo hallo ich würde gerne jetzt
zwei pizzen bestellen zweimal margarita
aber diese stellen ja ja dann können sie
die zum strand bringen geht das wohl wie
das geht nicht wenn diese auch eben doch
gar kein problem also wenn das nicht
geht dann stellen sie sich mal bitte zu
ihrem manager durch ja
darstellen und nach stellen was soll das
denn darstellen
ich glaube mit in einem film nachstellen
so das war unsere kleine episode über
das werk stellen und die vielen
kombinationen mit diesem werben
ihr habt euch sicher gefragt der mann
nicht in vielen situationen auch das
wort legen benutzen wie zum beispiel mit
schlägt sie mich auf den tisch dazu
werden wir bald noch ein weiteres video
veröffentlichen also seid gespannt
übrigens mit schlägt die mich auf den
tisch wäre nicht richtig
dann würde die mich nämlich auslaufen
wenn ihr jetzt noch mehr deutsche werben
und vokabeln lernen wollt dann probiert
doch mal den vokabeltrainer in unserer
apps idec aus dort findet ihr die 6.000
wichtigsten deutschen vokabeln mit
beispiel setzen und aussprache trainings
und bis bald
[Musik]
ja